[Musique]
et
aujourd'hui c'était une grande journée
pour un projet extrêmement important au
niveau de la recharge électrique en
france puisque tout un ensemble
d'acteurs de différents niveaux acteurs
industriels acteurs de recherche et
d'innovation est aussi représentant des
citoyens se sont réunis pour lancer un
grand projet de bornes de recharge
nouvelle génération de plus en plus de
véhicules électriques qui sont vendus
qui circulent mais il ya toujours un
sujet extrêmement important autour d'eux
des bornes de recharge et c'est tous
ensemble territoires industriels et
usagers que nous allons adresser des
problématiques concrètes opérationnelles
des bornes de recharge
il est important de synthétiser et de
rassembler dans une même vision un même
point de vue les contraintes et puis des
opportunités d'une nouvelle borne de
recharge nouvelle génération est
l'intérêt c'est vraiment d'avoir un
projet commun et non pas d'avoir une
multiplicité de tarifs une multiplicité
de normes techniques d'une multiplicité
de type d'usagé une multiplicité
d'acteurs qui vont fournir l'électricité
il faut avoir oui de multiples acteurs
mais par contre il y aura une solution
interopérable pour les usagers pour que
ce soit vraiment pratique pour ceux qui
possèdent un véhicule électrique de
pouvoir leur charge et indépendamment de
qui fondent et d'électricité leur la
borne de qui fabrique la borne est
également de quel opérateur ils ont
choisi pour payer la facture de leurs
pleins électrique très concrètement vous
avez une norme qui s'appelle une alarme
15 118 et l'enjeu c'est vraiment de
tirer maximum bénéfice de 715 118
notamment en fait avec deux bénéfice
opérationnel et concret qui est le plug
in charge facilité pour l'utilisateur
donc il est avec son véhicule et la
borne reconnaît automatiquement
le véhicule électrique le prestataire de
services auxquels l'usagé a appris un
contrat pour sa recharge électrique
donc ça c'est le plug in charge vous
avez un deuxième bénéfices qu'apporte la
norme 15 118 qui est la charge
bidirectionnelle alors derrière ce mot
un petit peu compliqué c'est un la borne
peut charger le véhicule ça c'est ce
qu'on attend en tant que service mais
aussi si le véhicule est bien chargé il
peut aussi détesté le réseau où on
voyait de l'électricité de sa batterie
pleine vers le réseau si le réseau
électrique a besoin d'électricité
donc c'est ça le sens bi directionnelle
ou une véhicule électrique qui a intégré
dans l'équilibrage général du réseau
électrique
ces résultats-là eu marre charging la
charge biais directionnel ce sera
opérationnel d'ici 36 mois il ya des
étapes intermédiaires et notamment une
étape importante pour l'usager c'est la
possibilité de programmer à l'avancé
grâce à ce nouveau service les moments
où il va pouvoir bénéficier au maximum
des effets du réseau vis-à-vis de la
borne électrique